the deputy leader of the labour party
angela rainer joins us once again very
good to see you um well let's let's
let's start with with universal credit
and of course we understand
we know what labour's positioning it is
but what is your assessment
of how much damage can be done by by not
continuing with this as teres coffee
said it was always intended to be
temporary uplift what's frustrating is
working people i find really struggling
at the moment two and a half million
will be hit by a double whammy of the
national insurance hike as well as the
cut to universal credit which would mean
over a thousand pound for the very care
workers and the key workers the retail
workers who have kept the country going
and at the same time the landlords who
have multiple properties will not pay a
penny extra on their income we think
that's completely unfair
again i go back to the argument that
therese coffee always always brings up
that this was a temporary measure and
actually when you look at the amount of
money that is being spent on it and the
amount of money that the government is
spending on many many other things in
the long term it's just unaffordable
it's unaffordable to plunge working
families into destitution and poverty
they've broke their manifesto pledge by
hiking national insurance up for the
working families two and a half million
and at the same time people who have
great assets and wealth and landlords
who may have multiple properties earning
lots of income from them will not pay a
penny more we think that's completely
unfair and the government have got the
wrong priorities and yet they're saying
they want to create more jobs but it's
all right to say that if you can't then
afford to be in work because you can't
afford to
support your family then this is
disastrous for our economy and
absolutely going to hit the most hardest
working families and those on the
smallest incomes the very workers that
kept us going through the kobe crisis i
think that's the slap in the face of
them never mind clapping care workers a
band 5 nurse will pay over a thousand
will see over a thousand pound cut from
their income because of this
government's announcement on the
universal credit as well as the
announcement on the national insurance
tax hike which they broke their
manifesto on let's talk just briefly
then about the national insurance
contributions hike i mean clearly there
is a massive problem in the health
service at the moment waiting lists are
as long as my arm we've got a problem in
terms of social care what would labour
do instead if not national insurance
where would the money come from well
waiting lists are a 12-year high we've
seen the 10 years of austerity i was a
home care worker for years many of my
colleagues were given voluntary
redundancy and those services were cut
because of the cuts to local government
funding and therefore what we need is
more investment in home care because
actually if people are kept out of
hospital and given the care when they
need it it costs us less and we've also
said yeah and we've also said that
people like private landlords on their
income that they generate people who
have
large financial transactions and assets
should pay more that it shouldn't just
fall on working people the two and a
half million working people that kept us
going through this crisis
are going to be over a thousand pound a
year worse off because of what this
government is doing that is unfair they
shouldn't do that that's fine but how
much money then okay for example could
you raise from landlords
well it would be a number of different
ways we're saying that it's not just
about particularly landlords yes that is
a way of because what we're saying is
income that's generated those at the top
have created more wealth for themselves
they've they've done well whereas those
at the bottom who have been keeping us
going through this kobe crisis are going
to be worse off we think that's unfair
the government should stretch it out and
those with the broader shoulders should
pay more not those that are on the
bottom run of the ladder those that are
in the lowest income are going to be
double waged not only by this national
insurance hike but the withdrawal of
those funds for universal credit that's
over a thousand pounds a year these
people are on huge amounts of money
that's going to leave them in poverty
and destitution that's not fair but you
know you know as well as i do the reason
that i'm pushing for for a more fleshed
out plan from labour because there are
people within your own party as we head
into conference season looking for a
better set out plan as to how to deal
with social care can we expect to get
more detail by the time of conference
well of course we'll set out our plan
and i've already said that those with
the broader shoulders should pay more
i've given you a couple of examples i
mean that's how that can happen
what's really important is i was a home
carer i delivered it in my local
community and we've shown that actually
if you deliver care in the community
when people need it that actually keep
them out of hospital so the waiting list
will go down the referrals and
admissions into hospital will go down
that costs less and giving people the
right care in their own home is actually
not only the right thing to do for them
for their care package but it saves us
money as well so it's a combination of
those with the broader shoulders paying
more as well as restructuring the social
care system so that people can get home
care when they need it this government
have cut home care they've cut those
vital services over 10 years of
austerity to local authorities and now
they're cutting the support to two and a
half million working families and making
them pay more that's not fair and at the
same time
landlords who have multiple properties
okay they're making a huge amount of
income we're not paying a penny more we
have made that point several times now
the point that i am making and i think
that others are making is that it's fine
for lib to stand up at the dispatch box
and criticize the government in terms of
their own policy point out the flaws in
it but time and again it feels that when
the question shifts to well what would
you do instead there isn't the level of
detail there isn't the granularity that
is necessary to provide an alternative
or even to say that you are providing an
alternative well i've just outlined that
and actually i said that when
and and let me be clear that when labour
was last in government that's when i was
a home carer we had uh mvq national
vocational qualification entry level at
level two so care workers were skilled
workers we had home care in the
community we had care homes that were
able to deliver care when people needed
it what i'm saying is ten years of the
tories have seen those cuts to local
government cuts to home care and now
we've got a 12-year record high in
waiting lists in the nhs that's because
of the policies of this government when
labour was in government waiting
literally were an all-time low for the
nhs and that care was given in the
community and home carers were given a
vocational qualification so they were a
skilled workforce that could support
people at home we want to go back to
that delivery model which will also save
the taxpayers money just in terms of um
the public health response to covert 19
vaccine passports have been well
depending on who you listen to in
government have been ruled and ruled out
left on the table don't want to use it
but it is an option what's the labour
party position on all of this should
covert passports be mandatory in for
example the night time industries in you
know stadium events what's your view
well what's really frustrating is that
there has been this confusion last week
i was at the dispatch box with the
minister telling me that they needed
covered passports in large venues and
events this weekend we had the health
secretary changing his mind on that what
we said and the welsh labor government
have introduced a policy of making sure
that we have risk assessments that's the
first thing we need to have mandatory
risk because different venues are of
different procedures they may have
different ventilation different sizes
indoor outdoor so it should be risk
assessed and we should have a
combination of making sure that people
can show that they've had the vaccine
but also even if you've had the vaccine
you can still have covered so free
testing must be part of that process as
well so that people can see if they've
got the virus and make the informed
decision to self-isolate and the
government have been completely lacking
in clarity here which is not good for
business you know this was supposed to
be implemented in a couple of weeks and
yet they've just changed it all again
this weekend businesses have struggled
over the last 18 months and what they're
saying to labour is they need certainty
and they want to be able to open up in a
safe way that supports people so that we
can get our economy working again and
this government is making that more
difficult
angela good to see you thanks for
joining us in the studio